Lauren winter ring any bells nap can't
say it does oh that Lauren winter third
floor last door on the left at the end
of the corridor
you
Lauren winter
sorry only see clients by appointment
wait it's 50 bucks I don't kiss and I
don't do any word [ __ ] wide by me
put your money on the table you got
exactly 10 minutes when the alarm rings
it's over okay
you should take your clothes off we hang
gone all day actually I'm not a customer
[ __ ] a cop I should have known what you
want a freebie is that it my name is
scott shelby I'm a private detective the
families of the victims of the origami
killer asked me to investigate the
murders I came here just to ask you some
questions about Johnny I already told
the police all I know and have nothing
to add leave me alone
I understand Lord I know what you're
going through oh yeah you know what it
feels like to find your own son's body
on a wasteland I'm sorry I don't believe
you have the slightest idea what I'm
going through mr. Shelby the killer is
walking around free as we speak he'll
kill again if he's not arrested hey
Johnny's dead so what difference does it
make I bought 10 minutes of your time
didn't I all I ask is that you use that
time to answer some questions you want
to pay me to tell you about my son is
that it you can buy my body mr. Shelby
but my son is not for sale get out of
here get the [ __ ] out
well if you remember anything the
smallest detail give me a call
Wow
Lauren Lauren open up baby it's me what
did you do I already told you I don't
want to see you anyone sorry del but I
really wanted to see ya what do you want
[ __ ] Lauren is everything all right
she's just swell no beat it loser you
again if you're looking for trouble you
found it a little [ __ ] shut up
Oh
I'll see you again [ __ ] are you all
right better than him I guess who is he
I next client who thinks he owns me he
was getting violent and I told him I
didn't want to see him anymore well you
should be careful you'll probably be
back sorry about the mess
mr. Shelby
thanks
Oh
come on
you